Jamie Lee Curtis
Jamie Lee Curtis's love for Michelle yo
is everything everywhere all at once for
me in the season of shiny things in all
of this tremendous amounts of attention
the nicest thing is that now I feel like
I have five girlfriends and there is a
Sisterhood for sure the actress won
outstanding performance by a female
actor in a supporting role at the 2023
SAG Awards on Sunday and celebrated by
laying a big old kiss on her co-star's
lips
yeah Jamie just straight up went for it
Jamie also gave a special shout out to
Michelle on stage where is Michelle yo
okay
you say Michelle I say yo Michelle
Michelle
yo I love you I love you I love you I
love you Jamie says Michelle's the
reason she signed on to do everything
everywhere all at once a movie that
earned Jamie her first Oscar Nam how is
a laundromat owner a karaoke machine
could constitute a business expense I
almost singer
of course when you have your peers reach
out and say we love what you do that's
the biggest compliment Jamie was with ET
backstage following her big win where
she dished on that smooch or at least
what she could remember of it obviously
you couldn't have predicted this which
means you totally didn't predict this
which means you probably didn't plan to
kiss Michelle yo too when you're going
to accept your trophy right I kissed her
you did then I kissed her I love
Michelle yo we were we love each other
during Jamie's acceptance speech she
also took a moment to poke fun at
herself and her nepo baby status
something she also joked about at the
beginning of the show I signed a
seven-year contract to Universal Studios
and starred in an ABC TV series called
Operation Petticoat which was based on a
movie that my father Tony Curtis nepo
baby
yeah the Halloween star is the daughter
of fellow Oscar nominees Tony Curtis and
Janet Lee I know you look at me and
think well nepo baby that's why she's
there and I totally get it I joke about
it because it's the thing that people
like to joke about but the truth of the
matter is
um I've been doing this for a very long
time and I'm I've never worked for
anybody I ever knew
I mean no one I've only worked with
strangers and so the truth of the matter
is obviously it was a it was a help I
mean look I'm not going to pretend that
there was no effect of having them as my
parents but
I'm 64 years old I've been an actress
since I was 19. and while she's been
working in the industry for decades
Jamie says it's all about having fun
this is entertainment this is the season
of shiny things it's beautiful attention
it's art and if we're not having a good
time doing it if we look super serious
there's a problem
because then the people watching aren't
having fun because we're not having fun
so guess what we're having fun
[Music]